I
would say the biggest challenge
todd as a woman in science is being a
mom.
It's really hard.
It's very hard work having children.
Um,
and I tell kids this all the time and
they say,
what's the hardest thing you've ever
done?
Because I've done so many space missions
and Hubble and pro your big project.
I like all the hardest thing is being a
mom.
Kids like 24,
seven,
you can't stop it.
It's always there.
And uh,
as a scientist it's hard because you
know,
my particular field of science and most
fields of science require quite a bit of
dedication to whether it's laboratory
work or in my case telescopic work.
I'm where I need to go places and do
things.
Uh,
having high quality daycare is by far
the most important thing you can do when
your kids are little.
You know,
I,
when I relocated,
I spent more time looking for daycare,
then I did looking for a house,
it was much more important to have good
daycare and I was fortunate to find high
quality daycare where I just totally
trusted it.
Then my kids were great.
They the absolutely fantastic kids doing
super jobs now and you know,
they're wonderful.
But you know,
I had to spend a lot of time and energy
doing that.
I also learned you must rely on friends
and family to help you out.
You can't do it on your own.
You know,
there's this people like y'all,
you know,
how do you do it?
I'm like,
well my neighbors,
my mom helps,
you know,
I just rely on other people.
That's the way it has to be.
Otherwise you just go nuts.
Uh,
so it's,
it's a tough balancing act and I also
learned that there is no such thing as
balance that,
you know,
on any individual day your life is
completely skewed one way or the other.
One day you're like dealing with child
crises and you're just coping.
And the next day,
you know,
you may be dealing with a work crisis
and just dealing with that over the long
run,
you have to find sort of the right
balance,
but you can't expect it to balance.
It ended the individual moment cause it
won't.
And once you learn to give that up lunch
and learn to give up the myth of
balance,
you know,
you can be a much more relaxed.
Personally,
I would encourage anybody who's
interested in any kind of,
and
if science engineering,
math field to go after that.
You know,
I am not about telling people,
become astronomers.
We don't need a lot of astronomers,
but what I want to avoid is that young
young woman coming along who was
absolutely fascinated in biochemistry,
but she's told,
oh no,
biochemistry.
That's the guy's field.
That's wrong.
You know,
and I,
I,
the best compliment I ever had was a
young person who I just met standing in
line to go to a concert.
It was like two years after the
shoemaker levy nine thing where I had
been in the news a lot and this guy and
all,
we were talking,
waiting to get into the concert and he
said,
you don't have love.
I am.
I introduced myself,
Heidi,
it's like you,
Heidi humble,
the astronomer.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's me.
He's like,
ah,
you're the reason I became a biologist.
I said,
Oh yeah.
How'd that happen?
He said,
well,
when you did that comment,
crash thing,
I just thought that was so cool and I
had really slacked off.
I dropped out of college and I was just,
you know,
being a slacker.
But I was so excited by that,
that I went back to college and I took
astronomy courses and I said,
well,
that's pretty cool.
And he said,
yeah,
but I hated astronomy.
I'm like,
well,
it's not for everyone.
He said,
I love biology.
And then went on to get my phd in
biology and like,
that's it.
That's what it's all about.
You know?
That's my message is don't be
discouraged by anything anybody tells
you.
You know?
In my case,
that's the science thing.
And I just ignored people who said,
oh,
girls don't do that and what blah,
blah,
blah.
I just went ahead and did it anyway.
You know?
Lack of fear,
stupidity.
I don't know why I just kept doing it,
but to tell young people,
don't listen to those folks that you
can't.
If you want to do it.
That's the message.